let's talk about college football and
the commissioner of the pac-12
is kind enough to to join us here a
fellow native new yorker
living out here on the west coast larry
scott of the pac-12 joining me here how
are you commissioner
i'm doing pretty well thanks for having
me richard you bet um
let's start uh i guess with the personal
if you don't mind uh is it true that you
and your family
uh contracted covet 19 and dealt with
that scourge yourself
uh yes uh in early july um
i got it uh from one of my family
members and then
all five of us had it so uh got to got
to experience firsthand
some of the some of the challenges and
also you know kind of the randomness
in terms of how it affects people um
from
my wife who is asymptomatic to uh myself
who had you know several days of
pretty tough symptoms so um yeah it
gives me a different lens
to look through all this with in terms
of how you contract it
uh the not just the impacts of uh
you know whether you have the virus or
not but those around you in terms of
those at the quarantine and
some of the mental health issues
associated with it and all that so
uh yeah just feel fortunate to kind of
come through it back to full strength
okay and um where do things currently
stand
with the pac-12 i understand last week
you made an announcement that coidell
labs uh and the pac-12 have come
together
um to um strike a deal over
rapid uh point-of-care antigen testing
and how you've called that a game
changer
where where do things currently stand on
that changing of the game
commissioner yeah so it's it's really
new as you mentioned we only just
announced this
last week came together fairly quickly
uh
at the end with quadell and so where we
stand is our existing
uh position is we're not going to start
competition before
january 1st and then and this uh
new testing arrangement which allows us
on each of our campuses to test our
student athletes
daily with immediate results uh is a big
big breakthrough but it's not the only
hurdle we have
you may be aware we've got half of our
league six of our schools the four
california schools usc ucla stanford cal
and to oregon schools oregon oregon
state that don't currently have approval
from county public health officials have
contact practice
you know given it for the nfl teams in
their
um in their areas but they haven't given
it for
our college teams yet i'm hoping
this testing arrangement will give the
public health officials more
more confidence that the student
athletes are not in
harm's way engaging in football practice
uh because they're being tested daily
and they'll be able to be weeded wait it
out so
but that's that's a step that we have to
overcome if that happens
uh there's a possibility we could
evaluate starting earlier
that january 1st you know we need six
weeks of training camp to ramp up
so we're not talking about starting
tomorrow even if even if we could
but there's now a crack in the door
where we could potentially start before
january 1st okay so in terms of
in terms of all this uh larry look
you're probably like me and everyone
else in the media
in the fact that you're trying to learn
public health on the fly in a certain
way that you never thought was part of
your job requirement yeah
um but how does this point of care
testing change anything
i mean does it catch asymptomatic does
it
does it does it where would you put it i
mean would you put it in facilities
would you actually put it in stadiums
where what
how does this work how does it change
the game larry
well you know we uh
these are in short supply hard to come
by as you can imagine
you know hospitals nursing homes right
uh
urgent cares have needed these and and
uh
our earlier estimates weren't we weren't
gonna have access to this kind of test
until the end of november so
so the big breakthrough is we're now
gonna have them two months earlier by
the end of this month
we're actually gonna have devices these
readers in our training rooms
and enough tests to test our football
student athletes basketball and other
contact sports
daily starting in early october and what
it allows you to do
is unlike the pcr tests which have to be
sent off to a lab
and again i'm not a doctor either but i
think i could get a degree
with a number of hours i put into some
of these calls unlike the pcr tests
which need to be flown to a lab
to be tested in the you know 24 hour to
72 hour turnaround time
the way these antigen tests are called
work is
nasal swab and within 15 minutes
you have a result now they're
considered pretty accurate but not as
accurate as the pcr test
but by taking them every single day
and getting the immediate result uh it's
believed
that there's a much higher degree of
confidence you will keep anyone that's
got
got the virus from practice um
this is going to also be done in
coordination with a research study
because it's just not a lot of data on
this it's also new
right uh to actually prove and so we'll
still do pcr tests on our student
with athletes to answer the question you
just asked
uh can this type of testing algorithm
every day
with immediate results do a better job
at weeding out asymptomatic and
symptomatic
uh positives compared to what's in the
current standard which is this pr test
every few days with the delayed results
uh
so we're gonna hopefully we can prove
that this works because it may then be a
pathway
to you know kids getting back to school
getting back to work
you know the economy getting back in
different ways because this study
doesn't exist
well i had a couple of uh mondays ago
stanford head coach david shaw on my
show and i asked him if he thought
that the pac-12 made the right decision
on pushing football
he said the word unequivocally now
put that together with this testing do
you think that
it's already moved the needle with
coaches and potentially school
presidents within the pac-12 to rethink
this decision how quickly
i know this is two questions but how
quickly can can you get back on the
field
have have opinions already changed
well people are immediately more
open-minded i think we prepared to be
flexible but
we can't revisit the decision until
uh the county officials in southern
california
southern california northern california
and oregon
give us a green light and bless it uh so
we can move pretty quickly after that
but um you know i was on a call already
this morning with football coaches at
our working group just you know
starting to look at some modeling but
really that's the next hurdle for us
rich is to
um see if we can get blessed to uh
to come back to practice and play by
public health authority
if so i think we'll move quickly to
answer that question well if you're
talking about governmental authorities
um word is that kevin warren um
uh your colleague at the big ten has
received a phone call from president
trump
on this subject has the president called
you larry scott
uh has not have not heard from uh from
the white house but i'm talking to kevin
um and they're trying to you know figure
out this testing thing too
and seeing if they could start before
january 1st as well
i mean given that our two leagues made a
similar decision we just we're not
comfortable with all the uncertainties
trying to start on time
we're now trying to see i'm trying to
see if we could align
our schedules so that not only can our
student athletes play for a pac-12
championship but maybe that'd be some
cool postseason
opportunities roseville and otherwise
after i don't know if that's gonna be
possible
kevin's got you know uh uh different
different pressures different points of
view
in his league but it's something we're
gonna fully explore well i mean let's
explore a little a bit of
different pressures and different if you
will um priorities we've got larry scott
pac-12 commissioner here
on the rich eisen show why do you think
the president hasn't called you larry i
mean
if he's called the big ten is there a
different
set of standards involved with pac-12
because the
the human cry hasn't been very loud here
on the left coast
uh although there are passionate fan
bases for sure i know them very well
to what do you owe this well
i yeah i don't know uh i don't know what
goes into the political calculus
but um what i will say is our conference
has been very aligned
and you have not seen a lot of
controversy you've not seen
coaches uh presidents governors lawsuits
parents
uh reaching out i do think we did a good
job
uh being very transparent um being very
communicative with the different groups
we have
as you heard from coach we've got a lot
of alignment about what we're doing
and so uh we haven't been in the news as
much
and you know we'll try to keep it that
way
and then uh other conferences are still
pushing ahead
larry do they have different signs than
you have they gotten different
information or are you you guys working
off the same information
uh i think we're generally working off
the same information there's been good
collaboration a lot of discussion
around between medical advisors and
different leagues uh you know look i i
um
don't want to disparage any other
league's
decision making everyone is under a lot
of pressure
uh and there's a lot of arguments around
every side of this issue about what the
right
thing to do or wrong thing to do um you
know
for us we put the health and safety of
our student athletes first
and there were just too many
uncertainties and not the availability
of testing
and without the government approvals
that as david shaw said
you know it was unequivocally you know
the right decision for us
at the time but you know like in a way
college football is something is a bit
of a microcosm of what's going on in our
country more broadly
i think the same science exists for
everyone
but you know can you explain why
different
states require masks and others don't
in some states bars are open and others
they're not um
so you know i think uh college football
has gotten caught up
in that a little bit too so then is is
there a possibility larry that that when
it comes down to it
you want to talk about pressures if you
and the big ten decide we're not going
and then we're all sitting here talking
about an sec game
where kids are a week later not testing
positive for covid
then the pressure i guess would would
land fully squarely on
on your conference in the big ten and
the other way shape and form is it would
be bad news for everybody because that
would mean that
kids are testing positive and we all
want everyone to be healthy do you think
larry scott that this will eventually
push
uh the ncaa and the power five
conferences to come together
with all due respect to smaller schools
and other conferences
where you just group up and have
everybody monetize it like it's a sports
league do you think that this might
actually happen larry scott
well first i'm cheering for
uh the success of the sec acc big 12a
because you want to want to be healthy
but b
if they're able to successfully get
through their season and finding out
that you know
playing football is not spreading the
virus
that then gives us more confidence to
move forward so we're going to learn a
lot from the nfl
we're going to learn a lot from what
happens in some of these other leagues
these weeks and i hope it's positive um
but i don't
i don't think we're going to see any
major restructuring in terms of revenue
sharing
or in terms of decision making there's a
long history to the way
college football works the extent to
which we're together is around the
college football playoffs and i think
that will stay in entity regardless of
how many
uh teams or leagues are playing or not
you know this will be revenue sharing it
still requires
all 10 conferences to agree on whatever
we're going to do but beyond that the
ncaa level
uh i think it's so it's very fragmented
and it's really hard to make structural
trains like you described
and um i guess crystal ball it for me
i get this question all the time because
you know being
on nfl network for as long as i've been
i hear it all the time
i ask it of players and coaches when
they come on from the nfl do you think
there's going to be a full and complete
season
and you know they're all trusting the
process that's been put together in a
but it's a professional sports league
do you think larry scott pac-12 football
could be will be played not could be
will be played before thanksgiving as
we're sitting here
tuesday after labor day i'd say it's
unlikely
that we're gonna play before
thanksgiving i mean we
we would need a full six weeks of
practice and training camp
uh to feel comfortable student athletes
are healthy and ready and not gonna put
themselves at risk of injury
um so i think that's probably
unrealistic knowing that sitting here
today
six of our schools don't have the
government approvals to move forward
uh but i wouldn't rule out post
thanksgiving
uh or again you know early january the
latest okay and what about college
basketball larry how about
here tuesday after labor day uh pac-12
playing before christmas
i know that currently things have been
pushed to right around thanksgiving
weekend but what do you think about
the possibility of pac-12 basketball
returning before christmas this year
yeah i'm i'm a little bit more
optimistic answering that question i
mean first of all the ncaa's going to
help us we've been lobbying them
and i think they're going to push back
the start of their season it was
supposed to start november 10th
now it's going to start i think you know
around thanksgiving
so that gives us a few more weeks um
secondly with this new testing
capability we have which by the way i
think is essential for basketball i mean
you've only got 15 guys
on a roster it's the closest of close
contact sport
uh there's no equipment in between you
you know you're basically
you know in close contact with the other
team
uh the whole time so there's it's
indoors
so there are additional challenges that
basketball has which is why the kind of
testing we've now got access to
i think is going to be so critical so
i'm hopeful
that with the uh the government approves
i talked about are still essential
for basketball in uh california schools
they uh can't practice indoors can't
touch a basketball
right now but assuming that's worth
comment i'd like to think we can start
around the time the rest of the country
is starting
larry thanks for the call appreciate it
i'm glad you and your family are
are healthy um and i i look forward to
getting you back on maybe in a few weeks
once uh college football might have
started in other conferences and vice
versa potentially thank you for the call
happy good thank you thanks it's larry
scott pac-12 commissioner